الى ملف حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وفي
التطورات الاخيره افادت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه بمقتل 200 جندي الروسي في قصف
لقواتها على احدى مناطق تمركز القوات
الروسيه على اطراف مقاطعه خرسون جنوب
البلاد
على طول ضفه الاخرى من نهر دنيبر في خرسان
اكدت الهيئه الطيران الحربيه
داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه اضافه ثاني الى
استهداف في المدفعيه الاوكرانيه سبعه
مواقع لتماركوز القوه الروسيه وخمسه
مستودعات الاخيره ومحطه رادار روسيه من
اخرى قالت هيئه الاركان ان القوات الروسيه
نفذت امس الجمعه
55 غره جويه على مناطق ذات بنيه تحتيه
حيويه اوكرانيه اضافه الى 80 هجوما
منظومات صاروخيه
استعاده السيطره على بلده نوفو سيلفسكا في
مقاطعه لوكاسكا بعد ان معارك امتدت اياما
مع الجيش الروسي
خسرها الجيش الاوكراني في المقاطعه
العدديه للقوات الروسيه
جديده خلال الشهرين المقبلين
تصاديه هل هجمات الروسيه على جبل